well police are looking for your help to
identify the person responsible for a
shooting that was caught on camera brian
yes police say the victim is a father of
three he was killed
on his way to work and christian casares
joining us live from the newsroom
with the plea from the victim's family
christian that's right denise and brian
it was an emotional day for the family
who is looking for justice for the death
of kashif brown
now they are hoping to achieve that with
the community's help now take a look
here on your screen this is surveillance
video captured
on march 22nd at the circle k gas
station
on valley view and alta police say brown
pulled up around 3
30 in the morning before heading to work
that's when a vehicle possibly a
2015 gray chrysler 300 pulled up and the
driver tried to rob him
shots were fired and the shooter left
now the description of the driver is
vague police only
saying it is a black man and there was
also a black female passenger
today his mother stood at the same
location asking for the community
support
i love my son very much and it's still
unbelievable that he's gone
i it's hard to believe
still i'm trying to wrap my head around
it
and i have to go pick up my son's ashes
today
well his family says brown leaves behind
a wife and three
young daughters now you can get another
look at the video on our website
eightnewsnow.com
again if you recognize the vehicle or
have any information please call
crimestoppers
the number uh hopefully right there we
can put on your screen
christian 702-385-5555 8 news now